Hello, everyone.
Welcome to the Active Inference Lab
and to the Model Stream 2.0.
Today is going to be a really awesome
discussion,
so let's just introduce ourselves
and get right into it.
I'm Daniel Freedman.
I'm a postdoctoral researcher
in Davis, California.
Right Yep.
So I'm Ryan Smith.
I'm an associate investigator
at the Laureate
Institute for Brain Research.
Hi, I'm Christopher.
I'm a Ph.D.
student at the University of Cambridge.
And I'm Max Murphy.
And I'll be starting
my postdoctoral fellowship
at Carnegie Mellon in hopefully a week.
Awesome.
Thanks to Ryan and Christopher,
the authors
or two of the three authors of this paper
for joining today
and for Max
for lending your expertize as well.
So this is the second model stream
in a multi part series
that is going to be highlighting
perspectives
and addressing questions
related to applied active inference.
And so right now we're looking at the
tutorial paper of Smith at all, a step
by step tutorial on active inference
and its application to empirical data.
The link
you can find in the video description.
So if you have any questions or thoughts
or comments during the live stream,
type it in the YouTube live chat
and we'll be monitoring that.
And then if you have any questions
after the live stream
leave a comment on the video
or get in touch with us another way
and we'll try to address it
in a future session.
And if you want to learn more
or if you want to participate,
go to active inference dot org.
All right.
So today in our second session,
we're going to be picking up
with a brief overview and summary
of where we're at, where we've been.
We're going to go through
a few clarifying questions
that have been raised in the last week.
And then we're going to dove into
the specific examples and into the code
and do some code walkthrough.
So that would be really exciting.
All right.
So I'll just throw out
the first opening question,
which is Who is this session for?
What kinds of tools and skills
would you say
are required and which kinds of tools
or skills might be helpful?
Okay.
Well, I mean, I would
say that the session and I mean, really
the entire tutorial is for people
who are just kind of
I mean, mainly people
who are just starting out,
people who want to be able,
who are interested in active inference,
but maybe don't have a lot of background
in mathematics, you know,
especially like people
coming from like neuroscience
and psychology backgrounds, for example,
that want to
or people
who do some computational modeling.
But like maybe like simpler reinforcement
learning models, things like that,
where active inference
is kind of notoriously a little bit
more kind of like black box, you know,
it's harder to kind of break into.
And a lot of people think that the models
are described in a way that's kind of
like opaque,
you know,
and so the the idea was to give people
the background needed
and the actual example code
that would be needed,
that could be adapted to build
your own models,
do your own simulation studies, and apply
and build models of task studies
and be able to fit models to data.
In other words,
to kind of start to finish, to be able
for a person who wants to to be able to
use inference models to model
data in empirical studies and actually
use them in their own research.
And so as far as tools necessary
you know, the main thing right now
is going to be having
some minimal understanding or motivation
to learn how to use MATLAB
So, you know,
we in the tutorial codes,
I mean, we have like seven
or eight different tutorial scripts,
you know, at this point.
But the main one
is the one that I'll be focusing on today
and it's very heavily commented.
So it kind of best we did try to describe
kind of like line by line
each thing that's going on.
I mean, it's
honestly there's enough comments in there
not must be kind of like a second
paper in and of itself.
So, you
know, we're hoping that even someone
who doesn't have a ton of background in
MATLAB will be able to kind of bootstrap
their way up.
But you definitely need
to have a little bit or be motivated
to learn at least a little bit.
Anything else to add on that,
Christopher or Max?
I think that sums it up well.
Just one note on the code there.
So you mentioned it's in MATLAB.
Now, what about other programing
languages or backgrounds like Python
so what other languages are people in
the active inference space developing in?
And how could we include
more computer languages
as well as natural human languages?
So I mean,
there are so at present,
everything is almost exclusively
in MATLAB, unfortunately.
And the reason for that
is, is that a lot of this
is actually built off of SPM scripts.
You know, the Karl Freston
originally wrote in relation
to neuroimaging approaches.
So things like dynamic causal modeling
and so and a lot of
a lot of the current scripts
for doing active inference
call on a broad range of other
SPM scripts that are used for a lot of
different purposes, for instance,
and sort of dealing with large matrices
in and like neuroimaging and so that.
So for that reason
and because Karl is primarily
working in MATLAB in relation SPM,
everything has kind of been in SPM
and specifically in
what's called the DSM toolbox in SPM.
12 stands for dynamic expectation
maximization.
There's a ton of active inference scripts
as well as a ton of other modeling
scripts for say like continuous models
and other sorts of things in there.
And we just make use of a couple of those
are the main ones,
not the ones they call on. But
but that
being said, there
are people who are trying at the moment
to translate some of this stuff
into Python.
Alec shots, for example,
is currently in the process
of trying to put together
Python versions of some of the main
simulation and version scripts
and I don't I mean, they're very kind of
in beta at the moment
as I understand them.
But I know I know that that's something
that's in progress.
Cool.
So it sounds like because this project
has such a history
of being developed in MATLAB
and the SPM toolkit and Coral,
for instance,
research and collaborations, we're
drawing heavily on MATLAB However,
in the modern development context,
there's a lot of open source projects
that are developing in Python.
So that's definitely an area
will hope to be expanding.
And also a great opportunity
for people who are experienced in Python
or MATLAB and want to be curious
about active inference.
This is the opening to help contribute
to something that could be really
exciting. So just a last,
last warm up introduction question.
What kinds of projects
or questions or investigations
do you think this could apply to
for somebody who they've
heard of scientific modeling
but not active inference modeling?
What do you think are some low-hanging
fruit or really straightforward
interpretations
where you think it could be applied?
So, I mean, I guess
there's a couple of questions here.
I mean, one is and may not like well,
I guess the main one is
given that the kind of history
of computational modeling has
largely been in the
like reinforcement
learning you know, sort of literature
or I mean, there are others
like director data and modeling
and things like that. But
the, you know,
one of the kind of major questions.
So a lot of inference models
seem like they're really complicated,
you know, relative
to some of these simpler
sort of traditional reinforcement
learning models.
So what is it
that active inference actually adds?
Right.
Like, what can you do using an active
inference model in a study
that you maybe couldn't do
or could do as naturally
using standard search of existing
reinforcement learning models
and you know, here, the kind of answer
that I would want to give
is there's a few parts to this.
One is that
because the
kind of value or cost function
in active inference is expected
for energy
as opposed to a reward function.
And because the expected free energy
has a reward, a reward component
and an information
value component,
then it's it's quite a bit more natural
and active inference models
to model, explore, exploit tasks,
you know, so tasks where the agent has
to somehow intrinsically assign value
to seeking information
and as a means of knowing
how to maximize reward eventually.
So there are and there are actually two
different types of sort of directed
or goal
driven explanation or exploration
and act of inference.
One is
what we just call parameter exploration.
And the idea here is
this is probably the closest thing to
reinforcement learning where say,
the agent might not start out
knowing what
the reward probabilities are
if they choose one action versus another.
So they will choose actions
that will help them
essentially learn best
what the reward probabilities are before,
you know, just reliably or continuously
selecting the same option.
Right.
Because that's the kind of know
which one's the most rewarding first.
So that's called parameter exploration
and that that, like I said, has analogs
and reinforcement learning
but doesn't have like a specific
in standard models anyway, doesn't have
a very specific sort of information drive
to to seek that out.
But there are some so that things
like information, bonus terms, different
things like that and reinforcement
learning that can do something like that.
But they're kind of tacked
on. They're a little, little
and a little more
kind of like ad hoc to them, I guess.
Whereas it kind of emerges
naturally from expected free energy
and active inference.
And there's also something
that's a little more unique
and act of inference,
which is called state exploration,
and that's more aware
you're just kind of choosing to move
to states that you expect will give you
the most precise observations
about what state you're in.
You know, so this would be the thing
like you don't know whether you're
in the green room or the red room,
so you should go turn on a light
so you'll know
which which room you're in,
right?
So that also falls out of expected
free energy very naturally,
but not out of a lot of other
traditional computational modeling
approaches.
The there's also sorry,
I could go on for a while about this,
but there's also something
in reinforcement learning models
that has to do with explore,
exploit called random exploration,
where people essentially start
behaving more randomly.
And if they're uncertain
and if they know they have to make
a bunch more feature choices.
But those values are typically fixed
in reinforcement learning models,
whereas the expected for energy precision
parameter and active
inference is actually
a dynamically updated version of that.
So it changes to remain driving,
especially the amount of randomness
and behavior that's
expected given past observations.
And so that's kind of nice.
The last thing I would say
is, is that active
inference has a very kind of specific
neural process theory associated with it.
So it makes very specific predictions
about the neural responses
you ought to see and studies
whereas most other models don't.
And so those are that's what I would say.
Thanks for the answer.
Any thoughts on that or any
other questions, Christopher or Max?
I would
just say very broadly speaking, active
inference is really great for modeling.
Decision-Making Under Uncertainty,
and in particular, perceptual,
various types of perceptual decision
making and in discrete state spaces.
So you can do anything from modeling.
So like Raymond,
I have some previous work where we show
that you can reproduce
a whole lot of kind of
classic visual awareness,
neural correlates, and like the classic
visual awareness paradigms for example,
using a hierarchical model
And the reason we can do that
is because it had
active inference has such a detailed
and rich process theory attached to it.
And so for me,
I think what's really unique about it
is that so there's lots of different ways
of providing unified explanations.
But one way that you might want
to provide a unifying explanation
is just have a unifying set of kind of
common
unifying computation
or one computational architecture
where you can draw in all of these
different things into one paradigm
and then understand, well,
one computational paradigm
that is, and understand
how they're related
through the different parameters
that are being modulated.
When you being fit,
when you build models, for example,
So I'm not aware
of any other modeling paradigm really
where you could model things as diverse
as a basic kind of explore exploit task
or looking at kind of basic
domain dynamics.
And then something that goes all the way
up to something like visual awareness
or even like planning and Belman
optimal planning.
So to me, that's
what's so special about this.
If you if you want to unify things
under one umbrella.
This is really.
Yeah.
One last thing I'll say, and this is just
kind of a practical, nice thing.
And so this is that they and most other
modeling approaches you actually have
to kind of change the equations,
you know, to set it to a specific
task.
Whereas an actual inference
technically you don't all you do
is that the actual update
equations are always identical.
All you have to do is write down
the appropriate generative model
so it's nice
because it's, it's really generic.
And, you know, once
you have the generative model
specified, everything else
kind of just comes for free.
And just to jump in off of that
generalizability,
the reason I'm interested, I
am somebody who studies movement at
totally different area of neuroscience.
Then decision
making and uncertainty modeling.
But at the same time, this framework,
what kind of interesting thing about it
is that exactly that, which is that
it seems that I can start out with kind
of a structured generative model
that is consistent even across domains
and then potentially use that to apply it
to my own neuroscientific research.
The main questions that I have
and things that I'll be interested
to hear about moving forward would be,
you know, we talked about that
we can use it both for parameter
exploration and state exploration
but when we're in
in the empirical context
of the experiments being performed for,
it might be the case that I'm uncertain
about certain parameters
or I'm uncertain about the state,
and I may be uncertain
about both of those things
simultaneously.
So finding a way to either
design my experiments so that I impose
certainty on either the state
or the parameters is probably seems to be
an important part of using this model.
Mm hmm.
No, no,
that's a great point. Actually, man.
Chris, we're just talking about this
like like yesterday or something
like how to design
an optimal task to disambiguate
but include both having to solve problems
that involves
state
and parameter exploration simultaneously.
Technically, the example, a
model that we have for
the tutorial is able to do that,
but not in an incredibly interesting way,
just in just an kind of way
to show that how you could do it.
Mm hmm.
Very interesting
about the experimental design
because the kind of statistical
techniques like a T test,
we know the statistical power
calculations or we might know
the kinds of experimental designs
that lead to good clean T tests.
But it's a great point
about the experimental design.
And just to highlight this generalizable
and also generative nature
we talked about a lot of different
areas of research,
a lot of different frameworks.
But the parts that stood out to me
were, Christopher, you said decision
making under uncertainty and action
and perception.
That covers a lot,
a lot of different areas of neuroscience.
And then we are looking for
this kind of unified explanation,
but rather than an explanation
which might be philosophical
or based upon how much we understand it
or how we feel that one day
we're rather going to look
for a unified computational architecture
or a computational paradigm,
as you said, that will let us compare
and design and develop these generative
and generalizable models.
So really cool discussion.
And I'm just going to ask one question
from the YouTube live chat.
Then we'll go
to Ryan with a screen share.
KB asks
Can active inference research
help us understand the neuroscience
of stimulus, independent thoughts when
there isn't any sensory input at all?
Thanks for elaboration in this regard.
I mean, I guess,
I mean, the broad answer is yes, but
the way that you would do
it would probably be pretty task specific
And, you know, so
so I'm I'm not necessarily sure
how to give a really precise,
detailed answer
without knowing the particular task
or even just general
psychological context
that's being imagined.
So, I mean, it's actually really easy
to model, for instance, like working
memory tasks where you might get
a stimulus at one point.
But then there's there's no stimulus
for a really long time.
And somehow the thing has to continue
to maintain representations
in the absence of any stimulus
to know what to do
you know, at some
distant future point. And,
you know, there's that kind of thing.
I mean, just as one example,
I again, like I said,
the way to answer
the question is probably is
it would be different depending on
the exact sort of psychological
or task context in question.
So just like explore, exploit
there are tasks that looked
more exploratory or more exploitative
almost within this action of perception.
We're going to be talking about
some tasks that are more towards
the action oriented side, like the policy
planning or the motor behavior
and other tasks that are more towards
almost the perceptive side,
like this visual awareness task.
Now, ocular motor movement, the movement
of the eye muscles is still a behavior.
And there's papers that model that,
but it's almost like
we're looking at the whole spectrum
of explore, exploit or action,
perception, reinforcement
learning and wondering how we can again
make this unified framework for talking
about these different kinds of systems.
So shall we jump right in right
or go ahead at anything else?
Well, I mean, us
I mean, just, just one last point
to bring up in relation to their
you know, this person's question
is just that it's actually
what's really important and probably
a more recent development
and this is stuff that
some of the visual awareness stuff
that me and Chris have done and also
some stuff that I've done previously
with like
emotional awareness, for example,
like levels of emotional awareness.
There's there's a real importance
of what you're doing,
not just behavioral actions,
but actually cognitive actions
you like.
You're selecting policies
that just do something like in the neural
implementation gestures, something like
change the functional connectivity
between two brain regions or change.
In other words,
it is stimulus independent
action.
They're actions that that have to do with
changing what you're doing cognitively
and not what you're doing behaviorally,
you know, so that's also an important
part of it that's been done.
And, you know, a few previous papers
that I think
relates an important way to this kind
of stimulus independence or a question.
But again,
only if I understood it. Right.
Well, good answer. And thanks for that.
So go ahead and
share your screen and just
however we can
help whatever you want us to do, or not
do, we're there.
But I'm really looking forward to this.
Okay.
So the you know, the main
the main thing here that I want to do
just to start, as you know, and this is
in part is because I'm assuming that not
everyone who's watching
today was watching last week
and so I'm not going to be able
to give you
a full understanding
of where we're sort of how we're going
from last week to this week,
but it going to give kind of
like a really sort of rapid
overview of where we're kind of going.
You know, so first we covered this
slide here, which just shows
an example of how you can do
and how you can do perception
as Bayesian inference.
And this is just an example,
a mathematical example of how it works.
But the idea is where you see this
sort of two dimensional image and you're
this gray thing under gray disk, under
observation, and you're trying to infer
based on prior expectations,
whether it's a three dimensional, it's
a concave or conducts shape.
And so the idea is, is that in
simple problems, you can do that exactly.
By solving
Bayes Theorem.
So this equation up here
on the upper left.
But in most cases,
that's actually intractable to do.
And so what you do in act of inference
is you instead
define this thing F here,
which is called expected for energy.
And it's more or less a measure
of the accuracy of predictions
minus the accuracy of beliefs.
And combined
with the complexity of those beliefs.
Essentially how much you have to
change your beliefs to
to get a model that's accurate.
And so by finding a set of beliefs
that minimize expected for energy,
in other words, ones
that are accurate
while changing as little as possible.
This is just an
example of how by doing that, by
just kind of searching around
for different cues here different beliefs
about the probability of states,
then you can find one
that when you calculate
it gives the lowest value for F,
and that's going to be the one
that's as close as possible to the true
answer the base theorem would give you.
And so
so we're
going to skip this one.
But well, so what you're trying to do
then an act of inferences,
you have some true thing
going on out in the world.
True states
and the observations that they generate.
But then the brain has this model
where it's trying to say, okay,
what state must it be
in, given that I got this observation?
So the brain is trying to essentially
come up with the representation
that best matches what's going on
in the generative process.
In other words, the thing that's really
generating the observations,
and so
that's probability of O
and so states and observations
and this pie thing is policies
So it's what's the most likely action
I ought to choose,
given that the world is this way,
and given that
I prefer some observations over others
and what's going to be important
for what I cover today
is the way that you actually set up
these generative models
and the way that these are set up is
you have these states
and you have these observations.
Oh, and,
and then you have prior, initial prior
expectations that we just called D
and if you solve this right,
if you get some observations
and you say, given my generative model,
what states are most likely
given those observations
and given my prior expectations, D,
then you get your sort of optimal belief
about what the
what the states
ought to be given those observations.
And but in act of inference,
we do this in a way that's also dynamic.
And so, for instance, states
that one at a time,
one are going to transition
into states at time, too.
And so you also have beliefs, this thing
and be about
what states are most likely
to transition into what other states.
And then.
And this is kind of one
of the unique moves in act of inference
is that policies
so the different action sequences
you might choose
are just models as things that entail
different transitions between states
and so be Matrix one, for example, here
would entail choosing
to move from one state to another state,
whereas some different policy
would entail a different be a matrix.
That means you transition from one state
to some other state.
And the choice of policy
depends on g here, which is the expected
for energy, which is a function of C,
which is your preferences.
So essentially what you're trying to do
is you're trying to find the policy
which corresponds
to a set of state transitions
that will generate the observations
over time
that are going to be as consistent
as possible
with your preferences,
which corresponds to having the lowest G.
And so and then there's
some other sort of parameters up here
that can say add habits.
So E here can give
you kind of an additional prior policies
that gives you kind of habits
to do one thing over another.
It can have this beta gamma thing
that also controls how precise
or how reliable
the model expects
the expected free energy estimates to be.
So I realize that's a lot,
but we kind of covered
this more slowly last time.
But what you really need to know
when we're actually putting together the
code, like I'm going to walk you through
and this is what we're going
to be specifying step by step.
We're going to be specifying
what the observations are.
the likelihood A.
So in other words, what states generate
what observations with what probability
we're going to
be specifying DMB, which are the priors
of our initial states
and beliefs
about how states are going to transition
and we're going to define policies,
this pie thing, which is going to tell us
the different possible state transitions
we could choose.
And then we're good to finally see here,
which is what the agent's
preferences are, what observations
it wants to get over others
as well as the habits and this beta thing
we expected for energy precision.
And so building a model on the code
amounts to just specifying
what all these things are
and what the state space is,
what the observation space looks like.
What A and B and B look like and what C
looks like, and maybe even better.
And so if you want to know
the exact equations for solving this,
you know, we've shown them here.
But again,
I'm not going to describe them in detail,
but basically all they're doing
as they're saying, given my beliefs
about state transitions and my priors
and given a my likelihood,
what's my most likely posterior
belief going to be,
which is just Bayesian inference
rate priors
and likelihoods together equal posteriors
or approximate to posteriors technically.
But so that's what we're doing.
I just want to.
Make one comment on that slide, right?
Yeah. Yes.
So on the top left,
we have state inference
given priors and given observations.
So that's kind of inference.
And we're going to be building
on these strata
to go from inference, Bayesian inference
to active inference.
So you go from the top left,
which is just perception at one moment
in time that static to the bottom left
where you have states that are updating
through time, given priors
and given observations, you're
updating your estimate through time,
then you go to the top, right?
So that so the bottom left square
adds in time.
Now, on the top right,
we add in this element
of policy selection or control theory.
And then on the bottom right,
we get all the way up to this
for active inference model, which
not just has a control theory element
through policy
but some extra parameters that help us
as we're going to find out soon,
like E and beta.
So just to give that one more time,
because this is what's unique
about active inference,
and this is the skeleton of the model
that everything else
is going to be scaffolded onto.
Thanks. Ryan continued.
Yeah. No, thank you.
I was definitely a good
a quicker, clear summary.
So appreciate it.
Okay.
So and then again, just to remind people,
the end goal of all of this is to learn
how to put together
and particular generative models, right?
Particular sets of matrices, d vectors, B
matrices, C matrices, etc.
and for
empirical.
So for behavioral tasks that
participants can do.
And then you can fit these models
to actual behavior
and to learn things about participants
for instance, you might learn
what their parameters are for A or for B
or for instance,
what their beta value is,
you know, etc.
And so that's the
that's the kind of ultimate goal here,
but the kind of first step to do that
beyond just understanding
the structure I was talking about
is to know how to actually put
that together in the code.
And so the last time I, you know,
I gave a bunch of examples
of past experiments
that we and others have done
where we have built active inference
models for tasks,
set them to data and, and learn things,
for instance, about differences
in substance use
and learning rates,
for example, or differences
in data and decision, uncertainty
in between healthy people
and people with depression
and anxiety or substance use
or differences in perception of precision
of precision estimates
for intercept of perception.
For instance,
So so I just kind of went through
these examples
of specific tasks
and empirical results
just to show the kind of thing
that you can do with this in practice.
The I'm not going to Riga and, but
and then the, the task
that we're modeling is one
that's designed to be really simple,
but that also kind of showcases
the major important elements
of active inference models.
And so here what we're
doing is we have a task
where the agent starts in a start state
and they can either directly choose
to pull the left
or choose the left slot machine
or the right slot machine
and if they do that,
they can either win $4 or $0,
depending on which machine is better,
the left or the right one.
But they don't know ahead of time
which one's better.
So they can either kind of take a risky
guess and either get $4 or zero,
or they can choose to seek information
first to ask for this hint.
And the hint will tell them
which the left one
which of the left, one of the right one
is better on that trial.
And if it's the left better context,
that means the left one
will win 80% of the time.
And if the hand says
the right ones better, then the right one
will pay out 80% of the time.
But there's a cost to taking the hint,
which is that if you take the hint
and then choose a machine,
then you can only win $2 instead of four.
And so that's what
we're going to be modeling.
And so what we need to specify for
that is
we need to specify that
there are two types of hidden states.
One is whether it's the left better
or the right better
contacts, whether it's a left better
or a better trial,
and also the behavior states.
So choosing to move from the start
state to the hint state or choosing
to move from the start state directly
to the left or right slot machine,
So that's two types of states.
We have to specify the observations
where in this case
the major observations
are winning the $4, $2 or $0.
And or in this case,
we're actually just going to model.
You win or you don't win.
And I'll show you how that works.
And and we'll have to define
the agent's preferences.
So essentially saying it prefers $4,
more than $2 and $2
more than $0
and that's going to be that sea thing.
And so so that's kind of the general task
structure.
And I went through
you know, the way to do this
kind of simply outside of the code,
which is you define
your initial state priors
and you define your state outcome mapping
how you define
your preference out
preferences of our outcomes.
You define the state transitions,
such actions and so be
and then you define the policies
which you define as this letter V.
And then
the final thing I'll talk about before
going into the code is that
and in this model, as you can
separate out the generative process,
so it's actually out in the world
generating observations
from the generative model,
which is the agent's beliefs
about what's generating the observations.
And if we want to separate
those in the code, then what we do is
big D or big A or big B,
and those are in the generative process.
But if you also specify
a little D or a little A or a little B,
then that's the generative model,
that's the agent's beliefs.
And if you specify those, then they will
be separate from the generative process.
And that's typically what you need to do.
That is what you need to do.
If you want a model learning,
which I'll show.
Right. Just just to two quick points.
So first off, someone has asked, will
these slides be available
or is there any resource where we can
look at these slides?
Because there's a lot
of great information on them.
I can make them available.
Everything, everything here is I mean,
almost all the figures that I'm showing,
other than the actual task
figure here are in the
R in the tutorial paper and
everything
I'm showing about how to actually build
the models is in the code and well,
explain in the code like I'll show,
but I'm also happy to provide better
this slides.
I mean, just, just let me know.
Like I said, the vast
majority of them are literally
just the figures in the paper.
So, so yeah, I mean, like I said, I'm
happy to make them available
or send them to anyone.
I can even just put them a supplementary
additional supplementary material
at the tutorial as well.
So I mean, yeah, just whatever,
whatever people want.
Great idea.
And what a fun and accessible science
we can have
when we just receive questions like that
and can put up our slides.
And then I think, Max,
there was a question
that you had about the B matrix
just while we're defining our terms.
What would you like to say about that?
All right.
So but just real quick, for anybody
who's just jumping in
on the stream,
the link is, is below the video.
You can go to their paper
if you're looking for that
supplementary code,
it's in the supplementary materials
you can download all of the code
from there, supplementary materials
there.
The question
I had was one thing to touch on
is as we walk through the code,
one thing I noticed
is that we have kind of a ten story
all structure for these matrices
where we could also specify
a transition matrix
that was that
had like a 2D structure with
width with probability of 0.8, 0.2.
But instead we have a ten story structure
where we have a fixed probability
of one for transitioning
from any given state to another state.
And I just thought
if you wanted to touch on
maybe the motivation for that,
I believe it's related to how the Model
Y basically interpreting
the model and, and,
and how the model gets used
is that
I didn't know
if you wanted to elaborate on that any.
Yeah. I mean, I mean, yes.
I mean, so technically, you know,
we call these things like we call
like a matrix and the B matrix matrices,
but technically they're sensors as though
they're high dimensional matrices.
And so, so
and you know, obviously go through this
when we go through the code, but
because you can have different types
of states, right?
So the state of being in the left better
or the right better context
versus the type of state
that has to do with, you know, where
you move to or what you choose, right.
That being in a star state versus
the hidden state versus,
you know, the left or right
bandit or slot machine choice state.
And because you have
two different types of states,
those are called state factors.
And so essentially what
you need to do
is you need to specify these matrices
or I guess a really tensor is that again,
this is for a
that say
what outcomes for each
type of outcome will be generated
for each combination of each value
for each state factor,
you know, which makes which makes it
you know, higher dimensional,
which is probably the trickiest part.
I'll explain this as well as I as
I can when we go through the code.
But so but so that's that's that
and also so simultaneously
because you have two types of states
here, that also means
you have to have a B matrix,
a transition matrix for each
type of state.
And when you when the agent doesn't
have control about state,
about transitions for a certain state,
then there's only going
to be one of these B matrices
So for example, here,
so this is just says
B four factor one,
which is what context you're in.
This is just a simple 2D matrix,
although technically for reasons
in the code, you define it as a
as a three dimensional thing with just a
one here this is just but that's just
because the third dimension here defines
the the number label for the action.
So this is basically
you're saying there's only one action
for state factor one,
and that is an identity
matrix here,
which just means that for each trial
it's going to be the left better context
through the whole trial.
Right.
In other words, within a trial,
it's not going to like after they take
the hint, it's not going to like
switch on them, you know.
So really the right one is better
if they got the hint
that the last one was better.
This is just saying
if you start in the left, better
one, you're going to stay in the left,
better one, the whole trial,
and that's it.
Whereas for the
stay factor two,
so the B matrices for state factor two,
there are four of these which correspond
to four different possible actions
and so here the third dimension
says this is action one,
which means that from any state
which are the columns,
you can move to state one,
which is the first row,
whereas the second one says,
if I pick action two
so third dimension value to that,
I can move from any of the four states
again columns to state to
which is the hand, the state
and so forth for action three action
for moving to choose the left band it
or the left machine
or choosing the right machine.
So these are going to be
the four actions, which are just
the four possible transitions
and then when you
specify policies, this thing in V,
this is just saying
for each state factor,
which of those actions
can I string together?
So the for one here for state
factor one is just a bunch of ones
because again, there's only one action.
It just stays in
whatever state it started in.
And each column here is a policy
in each row
as a time, as an action time
point basically.
So this is saying so the first row
here is what action could I take
when moving from time to time to
and the third row in the second row
here is what action could I take when
moving from time to time three and again
each of these columns just says
stand ones because there is no
possible action for changing the context.
But policy the policy for
space for state or for factor two here
so again the the actions and there's
these five columns and this just says
I can move to the start state
and I can stay in the start state.
Right?
So that's just action one up here twice.
And then the second column here
says I could take action to.
So look at the hint and then yeah,
then move to action three,
which is choose the left machine.
Or I could take the hint to
and then choose
for which is moved to the right machine.
Or I can go straight to the right machine
and then go back to start.
Or I can go straight to the arrow,
straight to the three as the left machine
or straight to the right machine
action four and then go back to start.
So so in other words, you know, there's
a bunch of other possible transitions,
right strings
that you might think of, right?
You might,
for instance, go to the left machine
and then go take the hint or something
like that.
But we're not allowing that.
We're saying
these are the allowable transitions
so these are the different policies
or action sequences that can be chosen.
So correct me if I'm wrong,
but it seems that this
sensorial structure
kind of allows us to compress
all those different combinatorial
combinations that we might have.
So it allows the structure of basically
just allows the code
to be a little more efficient.
Is that at the end of the day?
Yeah. That's
a perfectly reasonable way to talk about.
So, so, okay.
So, so that already gives
you kind of a little bit of a start here.
So now
and then and then in
so the end of the day, what
we're going to be doing as we're going
to be specifying each of these things.
So t the amount of time steps v
the policy space, a
the likelihood the state outcome
mapping be the transition probabilities
or transition matrices, see,
which is the preferred
observation that says preferred
status here but should be preferred
observations D It would be the priors
of our initial states
and then all these other extra
little parameters that you can
or cannot include
And I'll talk about this later,
but then we also specify this little D
which basically says the thing doesn't
start out knowing the context.
So that's the learn the context over
a trial has to sort of build up beliefs
about D over trials.
And so with that
as a kind of quick background,
I'm going to
now kind of move into the code.
It's cool that the whole thing is stored
as one object with a bunch of fields
because it's almost like
you could have ensembles
of these different models
or you might have a bunch of ants
in a colony.
It really lends itself
to being reproducible and transparent
with what each parameter is and comparing
a whole host of them alongside
or different kinds of models.
Just really cool to see that
instead of just a tangle of parameters
that you can get lost in.
This is like a column of things
that each has a very clear purpose.
Yeah.
So I should say to you, you do yeah.
Put all of these things
into the structure
that would usually result
little and deep,
which stands for Markov Decision Process.
And then when you actually run the thing
then you run it through the, the VB,
the SPM, MVP, VB, underscore X code,
and we've provided a version that just
appends it with the word tutorial
and you make that big MVP.
And then you can take is subsequent
commands like this that just m
generate figures that will show you
the outcomes of the simulation.
And these are examples of simulation
results.
But again, I'll go into these
after we go through some of the code.
And because
I know how to actually use this stuff,
you need to understand the code.
And so hopefully
I can make this not too monotonous.
You know, walking through code
isn't always the most exciting, but
the way that we have this set up
is you
know, like I said, we have comments
that kind of try our best to explain
whatever
that little command means, you know,
like what clear and close all mean what
our entry default means, you know, etc.
And I'm actually going to change this
to show
what that means is just that
the MATLAB
will use a random number generator
that won't do the exact same thing
each time
so we can get variable results
when we run it.
So we've provided
several different simulation
options on the we can use that
for building the model below,
which is what I walk through.
So if you set the SIM
variable equal to one, then
that will just simulate a single trial,
which will Rupert it reproduce?
Figure seven and in in the paper
that just be a single trial simulation.
If you set sim equal to the model,
simulate multiple trials
where the left context
is always active, but
the agent will know
that the agent has to learn.
Okay, the
the left one is the one it always is.
So after a while it'll be confident
and won't need to take the hint anymore.
If I could just briefly interject there.
So that would be for example, an example
of what we talked about earlier
is parameter exploration yes.
Well, well, not exactly.
It would be an example of learning
the parameters over successive
yeah.
So state I mean state exploration
is a bigger thing here, right?
Because, you know,
they choose to move to the queue
or not to learn which context it is yeah.
Yeah, I agree that.
So yeah, the tricky thing is,
is that when you only have two options,
then parameter exploration
would just amount to
even though I've gotten some good results
from choosing the the left one,
I might also instead
try to choose the right one a few times
to be more confident in what the reward
probability is for the right one.
But typically to get good dynamics
like that, you're probably going to add
something that has
has more like three arms, like three
different options instead of two.
If you're also going to include the state
exploration thing with the queue
it would get a little more complicated.
Like a standard kind of paradigm
for doing parameter exploration
would be something
where you don't have the queue
and the agent just has like three choices
and it just kind of has to choose
different ones over time until it becomes
confident which one is the best.
And then it'll just
keep choosing that one.
So the parameter exploration
would amount to
how many times kind of it it chooses each
slot machine initially
just to figure out which one is best
and standard reinforcement learning agent
will do that differently
than an act of inference agent.
And the substance use study I mentioned
above actually specifically did that.
But but yeah.
So just one question here in this SIM
equals one, two, three, four, five.
They're like scenarios that you're going
to be able to rapidly plug and play.
So scenario one is like a static
or scenario two is multi trial.
So this is what is going to allow
reproducible construction of the figures
and understanding of how different
parameter changes influence behavior.
But that's what
we're laying out right now
is kind of like the scenarios
for the agent, right?
Yeah, I know about quick is one thing
I think since I have to take about a half
now to run it.
Yeah.
Don't you SIM five we'll talk about
with the one we talk about parameter setting, which I'll be a different session,
but mainly we'll be talking about
SIM one,
two and three here, which just has to do
with perception and learning
as opposed to the real empirical stuff
which is estimating parameter
and using them for group level analyzes
and things like that.
Well, just so helpful though,
how it's laid out from the most static,
straightforward, perceptive inference
to action in the loop
and then now that actions in the loop,
we're going to think about the simplest
setting to explore action in the loop
on a single trial, unchanging.
And then we're going to keep on adding
layers of ecological variability
or other features into the model.
So thanks for making it
so step wise, and that's
why it's a step by step tutorial.
Yeah, yeah. We tried
but that's the last thing for for today.
So if you set SIM equal to three, then
that will simulate
a reversal learning situation.
And that's
where basically the left context
is active for a certain number of trials.
And so the agent should build up
a prior expectation
that it's just the left one every time.
So it'll stop taking the hint
and just start using left.
But then it switches.
It's in the right context
as the right one is the correct one.
And you see basically how long it takes
before the agent again says, Okay, now
I need to start taking the hint again.
And then eventually when it becomes
confident to just choosing the right one,
you know, directly
and not needing to take the hint.
And so it's kind of like a standard
reversal learning kind of task.
And so those are the three
that hopefully will get through today.
And there
are several parameters
that can be kind of messed with.
But the one that I've focused on mainly
here at least we can set at the beginning
is this our one thing
which just turns into hours later down,
but lessons for risk seeking,
or it could also be reward seeking,
but more or less, the bigger
this value is, the stronger
the agent's preference is for
winning as much money as possible.
So it's this is the value
that's in the C matrix
that defines preferences over
winning versus losing.
And so the bigger this number, they
the more the agent is going to say, okay,
I care more about reward
than about information, and therefore I'm
just going to take the risky choice to go
for one of the slot machines directly.
So the higher this less information
seeking, the more the lower
this is, the more the more information
seeking the agent will be.
And so that's
just kind of a really simple one
to show how by tweaking parameters,
you can get different results
here, just allowing you to wait
and how strong the reward value
component is in the expected
free energy versus how strong
the weight is of the information
seeking
component of the expected free energy
and then
kind of ignore this tab thing down here.
This is basically you can turn this on
if when you do SIM equals five,
you want to actually do group level
Bayesian analyzes on the parameters
and this will also save
the outputs of SIM.
Like Kris said, SIM
five like takes like a half hour run.
So if you turn this thing on, it'll also
save the results of SIM five so
you can run this PEB thing without having
to redo some five over time.
So we just figured hopefully that would
help.
I just, I just want to jump in
and point out that it's really nice
in this part where, for example,
with our cell set there, now let's say
that I'm designing my experiment
and I need to know how many trials and
how many subjects do I need
when I'm doing my power analysis.
I can run a simulation like this, set
that parameter at what I think might be
a reasonable range of values
from the literature
and then I can say,
well, this is the expected difference
in my groups
based on what I think
this range of values might be.
So it's a really powerful tool
to be able to plug
and play a single parameter like that.
Yeah, no, it's nice.
I mean, typically with experimental,
you know, with experiments
where you do want to do first
as you want to kind of say, hey,
can tweaking different parameters
in the model produce
simulated behavior that looks a lot
like the type of behavior
actually see in real participants
you know? So yeah. So exactly.
If you're hoping for as hey,
like there's a chunk of people
that look like that act
as though they have a high risk seeking
value and another group of people, though
they have a lower risk seeking value
based on their behavior,
you can fit the model to that explicitly.
And then you can say,
hey, is the difference in the value
between these two groups of people,
does that predict anything interesting?
You know,
does that tell you something about,
you know, how
well they're going to respond
to like drug versus drug B
or does it tell you something about,
you know, their general cognitive ability
or, you know, their current
emotional state or, you know,
like you can do all that kind of stuff,
which is the ultimate goal of all of this
but so,
okay, so the first thing we need to do,
at least in the order
I have it set up, is to set T.
So T is the number of time steps
and the trial so in this case,
there are three time steps, remember,
because the
the agent and
the agent has to start in the starts date
and then move to the second time
step, choose the hidden state
and then third time step, choose
one of the machines
or it can go straight from the start,
stage one of the machines.
But then at the third time step
it'll just go back to the start stage.
That's how we have it set up anyway.
So you need three time steps
so then what's typically
easiest is to first start
or start out by specifying the
prior expectations over states.
And so in the, in Big D,
which is the generative process
for factor number one,
which is in the braces here,
we just specify this as a column vector,
so a row
and then this means that it's transposed
and becomes a column that's
apostrophe thing here.
And so we set this as one and zero,
which just means that it's
with 100% probability
going to be in the left
better context
and then for the second step factor,
so this D two thing here,
we set it so the agent always starts out
in the start state
so a one in that first entry
and then zeros for all the rest
because it's never going to start
in the hinge state or in the choose
left state or in the right state
and we're just saying absolutely
the agent always start in the start state
but then this is all explained.
But then for a little D
so there's the agent's actual beliefs.
We say the agent has no idea
what context it's
going to be to start with.
And so we set measures to values
that are flat.
So where each the left better
and the right better context
have the same values.
But notice here
that we didn't set these up
to add up to one like we did for Big D.
I mean, the reason
is, is that these are technically
what are called directly distributions.
And directly distributions
are basically
they say the smaller these numbers are,
the less confident
the agent is in its beliefs.
So if these are point two, five and 25,
if thinks it's a flat distribution,
but it's really unconfident,
whereas this thing was like 20 and 20,
then it would also believe it's
a flat distribution but it'd be really,
really confident that its beliefs
are about a flat distribution.
And to explain that better,
we're actually going to transition over
to a Chris
is going to give you a little bit of a
kind of more general explanation
about how learning works here sense.
You actually do
need to understand this now
well so again,
transition over to Chris here briefly.
Yep. Because usually a probability
people would imagine it sums to one
something has to happen.
You know, the coin has to go
heads or tails, so it has to add up
to 100% has to add up to one
to be a classical probability.
But this is a little bit of a tweak
on that.
Some similar features,
but some unique features.
So thanks for switching over there
and helping us understand it. Yep.
So can you guys see my screen? Yes.
We don't see you, but we suspect.
All right. Go ahead.
Okay. Okay.
So as I was saying before, essentially
likelihoods
what we're talking about before
I say we're talking about the Matrix
there is, technically speaking,
a duration.
So all of the distributions
will be categorical distributions,
our days, our base and our eyes.
They're all categorical distributions
and they
all have a prior or a distribution
over the parameter space,
which is a directional distribution
and so just kind of the people
who are technically
in the know,
as it were, a categorical distribution
is just a special case of multi, multi,
no meal distribution
and additionally distribution
is what's called a conjugate prior
for the categorical in the multi
normal distributions, which just means
that if you multiply these two things
together, these two distributions,
you get out the distribution
that has the same form as the prior.
And that's really important if you're
doing like empirical Bayes, for example,
where the prior or the posterior
after round one
serves as the prior four in the second
round of inference, that kind of thing.
And so just to briefly go through this so
you can see my cursor, right?
Yep. Yep.
Okay.
This is the categorical distribution
where X is
a categorical variable
that occupies one of one to K
mutually exclusive state of the world.
So that is to say,
I have a distribution over a grid world
where my agent is my agent can't be in
two places at once at either end,
it's either left or it's right.
For example,
and theta are just the parameters
of that distribution.
And so this function here
is this thing sticking out the front.
It's this normalization constant
we can adjust it just to counter
the combinatorics
of the distribution controls.
That seems to one
exactly the same thing here
with the durational distribution are over
and it is a distribution over
the parameter space of our likelihood.
Right.
And so duration
distributions often kind of colloquially
called distributions of distributions
because they are a distribution
over a vector that has to sum up to one.
And then what's really beautiful
about these two distributions
is that when you multiply them together
and we'll just ignore the normalization
constant because things get pretty messy,
but you end up with a distribution
that it has at the same functional form
as the PRI. It's also duration
distribution.
So our posterior distribution
over the parameters of our likelihoods
is also a duration distribution
and all that changes
when we go from the likelihood
is we add this little alpha thing
here, it's called account.
So essentially it's add account
to whatever it was that was observed
to the variable that was observed.
So I'm just going to go into a little bit
more detail
than that on the next slide.
Is there anything
you wanna add to that, Ron?
No, I mean, just just,
I mean at the, at the end of the day
and you know, first Chris will,
Chris will cover this, you know,
I'm sure is that
while this might look really complicated
to somebody
who doesn't have a lot of math background
it really just amounts to there
being like what I showed you
with D there being a number
that's assigned to each entry
and when you observe something,
that number will get bigger.
And so that just means that
like what I said, that for instance,
if I believe
that I was in the left
better state the last five times,
then I'll add like
five numbers you know, I'll add
15 times to that left one.
So now it would be like 5.25
as opposed to just point to five.
And ultimately
those numbers get soft maxed.
So they just get normalized and turned
back into a probability distribution.
But but like I said
at the end of the day,
you're just adding counts
each time you observe something.
Yeah.
This is just like how
you might be a little bit more confident
about the true ratio of different kinds
of colors of balls in an urn.
If you had three of one color
and then one of the other color,
you're not quite sure if you had
3,000,001 million, you'd be very sure.
And then, Max, you had a question Yeah.
So just go
into the other end of the spectrum.
Then if I'm somebody who's in probability
theory and I'm talking about a dinner
slide distribution
and I'm talking about the support
for that distribution
on the open interval 01.
And as we can see here
from these equations that are provided
that if I go to zero,
then I'm basically going to end up
with a since it's multiplying each time,
then there could be problems.
So in practice, however,
my question
not being very experienced
with using these things in practice
when we implement this,
does that have much of an effect
on any of the estimated parameters no.
But one thing to say is that
because you always work with log you,
we always in log space,
we end up once you just have basically
a little numerical trick
where all of your to make sure
that you never have a log of zero.
We add E to the -16 to all entries
Does that kind of answer your question?
Yes. So if up for example,
if I see at the end of the day
I might have a converged parameter
that has apparently a very low log
likelihood of you know when I
when I converge on that estimate
is, you
know, maybe part of that could be related
to okay.
There's some times
where I am entering in a state
that might be unlikely
to occur most of the time
or maybe it wasn't observed
in this particular set of experiments.
But the rest of it kind of holds up.
Is that maybe one way to think about low,
low values?
When I converge
to my parameter estimates.
And I'm not sure I totally understand
the example just because it's a bit
a little bit abstract,
could we give a how.
About the slot machine example?
It's like you go into the casino, you've
never done any of the slot machines.
It's like you haven't
had much experience.
So even if you're
not sure about which one's better,
it's like you're not sure overall.
And then as you try more of the slot
machines, just like Ryan was saying,
you increment up observations,
so to speak, in those columns.
So after you've made a thousand slot
machine visits, you're
a little bit more confident than after
you had made zero or one or few.
Is that the case just to bring it
to the example that we're going.
To be there?
Yeah, or I could pull the slot machine
three times and get Y only one result
observed, and I would never have
the compliment to that result observed.
And so then effectively my,
my probability distribution
is then one and zero on my posterior.
So if I end up having like weird
looking numbers in my on my converge
parameter estimates in terms of the log
likelihoods for the different things,
it kind of maybe just relates
to this particular property.
But at the end of the day,
what it sounds like
is that I'm still going to converge
to the correct values using this approach
that's just like kind of an insurance.
Yeah, I'm not sure honestly about any
if there any formal results
that relate to this
but in practice,
because we always basically
the categorical distribution is just
and it just ends up being a self
max function
over the concentration parameters
you always have something
that's between zero and one.
And the concentration parameters are
basically will always kind of
be somewhere between zero.
It's never been observed. And
whatever it is, it goes to however high.
All of our main experiments,
you run all simulations around
I've never encountered a problem
with this,
but then again,
I've never actually really looked into
possible consequences of that,
so I just don't know.
I'm sorry, Ryan.
I don't think so.
I mean, the only thing I would say
and yeah, and maybe,
maybe I misunderstood the question,
but I mean, if it has to do
with whether or not ill,
there's certainly no guarantee that
you'll converge on the,
on the on the trigger generative process.
Yeah, there's, there's lots of cases
where things can go wrong
and you'll get stuck in local minima
and things like that.
And we actually show several examples
of that in this structure.
Learning paper
and where we show you how you can use
active inference for structural learning
and like Bayesian model expansion
or Space-Based expansion and say spares
production and things like that.
There's, there's lots of cases where
you'll end up with the wrong likelihood.
So, so it's not uh, yeah, it's.
Or maybe in my mind just a caveat
would then be,
you know, if it going to that example
with the posterior distribution,
I only have pulled the,
or picked a machine three times.
When we're designing our experiment,
it might be important to consider
setting it up so that,
you know,
we're not going to get into the case
where we only have a sample of N of three
because obviously that doesn't
sound like good science
to anybody anyways, but
it's just kind of the oversimplified case
where as you add more categories,
you could run into that scenario
for one of your particular categories
which could cause some problems. I.
I like if there's 100 kinds of serial
and you only let people choose
one time,
you're not going to get a good estimate.
It's kind of like a sample size
and an experimental design question.
So just to kind of pull back for those
because that's,
that's a really interesting question
about where there's proof
ability or how different sample sizes
are related to each other.
But we're just thinking about this,
the structure
for how additional observations
are going to increase the kind
or the the quality of this estimate
of the parameter.
Yeah.
And you also and you'll see
in what Chris shows you that that like
the basically the the lower
the concentration of the concentration
property values are generally
the more the expected free energy
will be weighted toward choosing
like parameter exploration policies.
Right?
So it'll be a thing
where if it's never chosen the 99th
serial before, it'll be driven to go
choose that one just
because it wants to be more confident
in what the actual parameters are.
But anyway I personally.
Yeah, go ahead.
Yeah. Yeah.
So we actually don't
yeah we actually don't have any numerical
examples in a paper where we kind of
have to show the fringy values
for different parameter values.
We only kind of have state
exploration terms, but there are,
I mean, maybe that's something
we could add to the paper actually.
That would be something interesting.
Yeah.
Yeah. Okay.
So essentially,
just to kind of give a recap,
we just have our
ADD probability distribution over a
all the parameters of A
is just a directional distribution over
kind of over A and then so we just end up
with a matrix that has at the root
where the rows are possible observations
and the columns are hidden states
and literally all that we're doing this.
So this little time,
this little kind of cross inside
the circle is called current.
It contains a product
that is that goodness.
That is that correct?
I actually don't know.
That's the notation.
Ross product and.
It's in the SPM textbook.
That notation is used
for the Cronica product.
Yeah. Thank you.
Okay, good.
Sorry, I just had a brief mind blank.
I was like, oh god.
Anyway, so and there's eight thing here
is just a learning, right?
And so whatever, it will
just multiply essentially this year.
So say I'll just give an example
and we'll just add that
to our previous values
of whatever these A's are.
So just very simply say we have
our posterior states
is something like .7.3 and our OB
we receive observation.
So this is a transpose
vector.
So this corresponds to road to this
all that this would do,
if we're literally adding a value of point seven and point three to this matrix,
that's all the planning is really.
It's very simple.
And then both of these things will get
both of these
columns will get passed through
SoftBank's function
at the end of the day,
just to kind of give a give an example
of what we're talking about before.
So because they're both soft, maxed
all itself, my old self Max cares about,
is that the difference
between the two numbers
in all the two elements of the vector.
So 51 and 52 and one
the same, same value in the soft max.
But in one case
the model is incredibly confident
and the other case
is not confidence at all for example.
So if you had an agent that was actually
doing parameter exploration,
there would be no
the agent would have no motivation
whatsoever to explore the parameters
in the first case of 51 50,
but it would be quite motivated
in the case of 21, for example,
even though the likelihood distribution
you're not getting
out of that is the same.
Okay, good.
So that is actually,
I think all that we really had.
That's all that I'd prepared for this
is because it's really is in practice.
It's so simple
So back to you.
Right.
Okay.
So Okay.
So anyway, with
that has a little bit of the background.
All right?
All we're doing here is we're saying
to start with, the agent believes
it's a flat distribution, has no idea
which one's going to be better left
or right on each trial.
That's in little D
because that's our model.
So each time it
believes that it was in the left better
context, it's just going to keep adding,
you know, numbers to this point
to five here.
And those will be scaled by that learning
right thing that
that just showed where, you know, if,
if learning rate is one
then you're trying to add observes
the left better context.
I'll just add a one
so it'll become 1.25 and then 2.25, etc.
But if the learning rate was like 0.5,
so it was like lower,
then it would add
zero point fives each time.
So it'd be 0.75, 1.25, etc.
So the learning rate just scales
how big the counts are.
They get added.
And the learning rate
could be zero, at which case
there wouldn't be an updating.
Just thinking about just
what could the whole range be
from not learning agents to very slowly
incorporating new information,
using this seriously framework
that Christopher just described
all the way up
to just ridiculously high values.
So that it just yeah.
I should just highlight as well.
I think that is this is I just kind of
want to this probably isn't a good point
for discussion
just to keep things moving.
But one thing that's worth highlighting
is there's a genuine kind of debate
or maybe debate a bit too strong a word,
but discussion to be had about
whether we should actually be modeling,
modulating learning rates
given that the model is Bayes
optimal or Apr Bayes optimal.
One would assume that there should be
a way of modeling things
about actually changing
the learning rate from one
but in practice,
I'm not sure if that actually works.
But anyway.
So yes, I mean,
I mean technically, technically
a learning rate of one is optimal yeah.
But for but for,
for when you're fitting behavior,
when you're fitting the model to behavior
and most people are not optimal.
And so you have to estimate
typically the learning rate
for each person and oftentimes
it's quite a bit below one.
But that's actually an interesting
attribute.
And again, it's an example
about how using these generative
and generalizable frameworks
help us compare not just
who could remember more numbers
or who had a faster reaction time
as far as just observable
characteristics.
We're moving a step back
and asking whether people might differ
in their learning rate
or in other attributes of this model.
And there is also and
again, I mean, this isn't something
to really get into so much,
but there is effectively a learning rate
that comes out of the precision
of your posterior beliefs overstates
and like, for instance,
if you're opposed to your beliefs,
other states are really imprecise.
Like say it's like point,
say afterwards, you know,
this is like point six, point four.
Then whatever observation that you get
is just going to add counts of point
six and point four, which means that
you're not really going to build up
strong priors.
You know,
a strong of a
more precise priors
for one over the other
because
you're not confident
about which state you're in.
With.
Just a quick example of that,
you go into the casino and you're drawing
a card and you can't read the card
or the numbers rubbed off.
So if there's no precision at the sensory
level with which card you drew, you're
not going to be updating your estimate
of how likely different numbers are.
And then if there's
a perfectly legible card
so it's 100%,
you have no error about which card it is.
There's the secondary question about
how much you update your internal model,
but it's not a precision
about the perception question.
So it's really a nice point and it's
worth understanding that you can have
uncertainty about observations
that then is captured by this model.
But also even in the case of precise
or even totally observable scenarios,
there's additional uncertainty
related to learning
Yeah.
I mean,
again, there's still potential problems.
I mean, what tends to happen in
these models
is especially if learning rate is one,
then the agent kind of becomes
too confident too quickly
or a better way to put it as they once
they've like observed a certain number
of like left, for example,
becomes really hard for it
to unlearn that
which is different from what humans do.
Humans tend to infer that
there's a different context, like, okay,
I know now it's the, oh,
it's a new context where right is better.
So it doesn't necessarily
unlearn the original
counts and instead sort of infer
now I'm in a new state
and I need to accrue different counts
for that state.
And that requires more complex models,
which can also be built just.
But that's not that's
kind of like humans using narrative
to help reset local parameter estimations
like, oh, well, now it's a new day.
So now things
that were unlikely yesterday.
Now it can be likely today.
And also it relates to this question
about the optimal learning rate
in a mathematical
or an analytical framework.
Maybe one or some other number
is, quote, optimal.
But then in a realized
ecological setting,
it might be actually not the best
solution in that setting.
Yeah.
And so, I mean, yeah, typically people
talk about this in other literature
as being like laden cause inference
really like inferring related causes
behind things.
So there's different latent cause.
And it's kind of the same thing as saying
there's a different context
and therefore a different likelihood.
But, but yeah, so, so I'll just
kind of, you know, go through this here,
you know, kind of step by step.
So, you know,
so I so I'm going to set up, right?
So I have
I have my big D in my little D here.
And then the next thing I'm going to do
is I'm doing this a little bit, you know,
condensed is to just set the number
of states here for each state factor.
So that's going to be the length of
do you want in the length of D two.
So this one's going to be
the two contexts
there's going to be two states
and this one's going to be
the length of D two,
which is going to be four states.
So at the end of the day,
this next thing,
if you look on the right,
is just going to look like that, too.
And for.
Just one.
Note there, for those
who are unfamiliar with MATLAB.
So at line 148 where noise is,
you put a little red dot like a stop sign
and then you hit run, which ran
everything that we had just discussed
from a clean slate up to that line,
and then it halted.
So that's
what allowed us to actually instantiate
all these variables
we were just talking about.
And then you stepped
just one line at a time
so that you could run this line
one 48 with all of its prerequisites
fulfilled So it's kind of like a break
point in the program.
We took a breath
and then we ran one line, and so now
we're going to go step by step.
Yeah, it just allows you
to kind of see who was doing step by step
which is, yeah, it's helpful. So sorry.
I should have said what?
Players and stuff and stuff like that.
And so, so now that I've specified
that I can put this little four
loop thing which just says
for that
four I equals one to the number of states
or factor two,
I'm just going to make it
all the no hint.
This is just saying for all the matrices
in a one to start with,
and everything is just going to generate
the no hint observation
so it will end up just looking
like this where
and so I just have
so this is just saying,
and I should say that the columns
correspond to the first day fact
or so left contacts right context
and the third the third dimension here
one, two, three, four.
That's what corresponds
to the second state factor,
which is the the behavior.
And so this is saying
when I'm in the start state one,
each context is going to generate the
no hint observation when I'm in the hint
factor, it's going to generate the
no hint observation and so forth.
So I'm just starting it that way.
Four is to say that they're all that way
but then what I'm going to do
is I'm going to define this thing,
which is the probability
of the hint being accurate
and and again, this is just kind of
to make things
a little bit concise and convenient.
And then I'm going to replace that a two
because remember a two means
I'm in the hint state.
And so I'm going to say
when I'm in the hint state,
column one and column one here,
I'm going to observe the machine
left hint with some probability
if I'm in the machine left state,
which is the left column,
and then one minus that for the
no hence state.
And again,
if I'm in the right, the right better
context to the right column here,
then it's going to be the reverse.
I'm going to observe the right machine
with some probability.
Just one, one note on that. Right?
So people might look at this and wonder,
why didn't you just say hint
or no hint instead of this one
-1 equals zero.
And this is because as you've had it, it
generalizes to cues
that are less than 100% accurate.
So then you could have the probability
of the hint being accurate
to being 90% or less or some other value.
And so if you have a probabilistic
learning task, you can model it
with this exact framework
just by changing
equals point
something rather than re-imagining
the entire matrix multiplication,
which is really the hard part.
Yeah, exactly.
So. So so if I step through that,
then in this case
I've set it to one, which just means
the hint is completely accurate.
So now if I look at A1 again,
then it's going to look like this
where all the other behavioral states
so in the start state
in choosing the left state
or choosing a left machine
and choosing the right machine
they still generate row one here.
Both of both contexts do the no hint.
But if I'm in state two,
which is the hint behavioral state,
then if I'm in the left machine,
if I'm in the left state,
then I will observe the left
is better hint with probability one.
And if I'm in the right column here,
the right context is better state
that I'm going to observe the right hint
observation.
So the bottom row here
with 100% probability.
So that words, if I observe this thing
that I'm going to know for sure
that I'm now in the left better context.
But if again,
if I made this like .8.2, .2.8,
then that would just mean, you know,
there's some probability
that the hand is going to
give me the wrong answer.
So that's so that's all that
as I remember the first state factor is
the columns.
The second state factor
is going to be the third dimension.
That's kind of key
So now what I'm going to do
is I'm going to define
the second outcome modality.
So this is another thing it's important
is that the the number here for a
that's in the braces
that corresponds to the outcome modality.
And so the first set of observations
I can get
is no hint
machine left hand and machine right hand.
So that's one set of observations
I would call like an observation
or an outcome modality.
Now for
a to the second observation
or outcome modality,
the possible observations are null
or loss
and win.
So this is saying is for the first
two behavioral states for
I equals one and two.
And the so being in the start state
or the hidden state is always going
to generate the null observation.
So it's not going to generate a loss
or a win
Now, after that, if I step through here,
I can set what I just called P
when so the probability of winning
and I set that to be point eight and
and this is the part
where the actual reinforcement
or reward learning comes in,
because what I can do is I can say, okay,
if I'm in the left,
choose the left machine state.
So three then
the probability of
winning, the probability of losing
is one minus P
when and the probability of winning
and the right one or the probability
of losing in the right one if I choose
the right one is high right,
which makes sense, right?
Because if I'm
in the left better context,
then if I choose the right column, right?
If I choose the right
machine,
then I'm most likely going to lose
in contrast,
if I'm in the right better context
and I choose
if I choose the right machine
and I'm in the right better context, then
the right column here should generate
a win with high probability.
So this is just saying
if I choose the right machine,
that's the for and I'm in the right
client, right better context,
which is the right column,
then I have a high probability of winning
and vice
versa up here if I choose the left one.
Again, just to talk about how
this is the minimal example,
we're talking about two options
with the two slot machines.
There could be more options.
We're talking about how much it costs
to get the hints
and how much it costs when you win
or how much you receive when you win.
That's a parameter
you can change how accurate the hint is.
You could have a perfectly accurate hint
that sends you to the slot machine
that wins 100% of the time.
So the probability of winning
can now be changed.
So then you can say, Okay, I'm
imagining a situation where there's
a perfect messenger with a hint
and that it's free to visit that person,
and then it's 100% likely
which slot machine is the winning one.
Or you can imagine these more gray
zone scenarios where different
things are associated with each other
in a less direct way,
or there's more than two options
just for those who are like seeing
this one example for the first time,
this is kind of like the tip
of the iceberg of a big, big family
of different kinds of models that have
a lot more options and a lot more nuance.
Yeah, I mean, you could have,
you know, 20
outcome modalities and ten state factors
if you wanted to.
It would just mean that like
there'd be a fourth dimension
for the third set factor
and a fifth dimension
for the fourth state factor.
And you know,
let's just get really big, really fast.
But so now that I've done this
because I set the probability
of winning 2.8 and given that you're,
you know, in the correct context,
then a two will look like this.
So this just says,
if I choose if I'm in the start state,
I don't observe,
I never observe a winner or loss.
If I'm in the hit state,
I never observe a winner, a loss.
And if I may, if I choose
the left option, the left machine,
then I will win with 0.8 and lose
with point two.
And the opposite four.
If I choose the right one right,
I'll lose with point eight.
If I if I choose the left machine
and I'm in the right context,
and if I choose the right machine,
so stay at four here,
then the probability of winning is 0.8.
So the third row here is winning, right?
And oh, point two and vice versa.
So this is just defining
the probability of winning,
given your choice, given
whether it's the left better
or right better context
and I know that's a mouthful, but
yeah.
So then finally and this isn't really
all that practically interesting,
but it's important to include us.
Is that what this just says?
So I'll come at three
is it just the agent's own behavior?
So what this means is every single time
it makes a choice,
it observes itself making that choice.
And all that does is make the agent
completely confident about what it did.
But you can imagine,
if somebody weren't aware
of their own Decision-Making behavior,
you could imagine that might lead
to decision making.
That's not in line
with what you would do.
If you could observe your behavior.
Yeah.
So, you know, I mean,
if you if you get rid of this,
then in some cases
the agent won't be able to confirm
what he did.
And so, therefore,
it will be hard for him to uh,
or to learn
what actions were the right one
because we don't know,
like what it show is.
Basically, it'd be like choosing a slot
machine blind.
I just want to jump in with a question
about my motor systems context.
So, for example,
if I'm studying sensory motor integration
and I'm measuring motor cortex signals
from neurons and motor cortex,
and I'm measuring outputs
such as the kinematics,
the kinetic forces that are generated
and the EMG signals in the periphery.
I could then use that that context
to say I could specify that as either 11
or as 01.
For example, if I didn't think that it
was capable, observing its past history
or its its decision states in the form
of some kind of a sensory blockade
related to my experiments
would that be a practical application?
Does that have face validity
in this context,
given that I'm measuring those signals.
One that just collectively flag,
generally speaking, in
motor control domains you're working
with like continuous quantities, right?
Right.
And that's why you use things
like common filters, etc.
as your models.
I'm not
sure to what extent
a part of the observable Markov decision
process would actually be the appropriate
generative model for the situation.
I think it would be
if you want a model like the decision
making processes observed
for motor control.
So am I going to move my arms
the left or the right?
That is a discrete decision,
but actually measuring motor control
and a lot of those things that you are
talking about, those continuous signals,
I'm not actually sure you know,
MDP is the appropriate generative model.
But for example, if I thought that
I had a stage space that consisted of a
a fixed point or any kind of, you know,
however, an abstracting of those
continuous processes into the realm of,
you know, a discrete state,
just glossing over that
this kind of model
could maybe account for that.
Or do you use. Me using that word in any
I mean, in
any case, you know, or
where a signal is technically continuous?
I mean, you know, the term
to use these sorts of models, right?
You're going to have to
just pick some quasi arbitrary
or maybe just by in some sense way
to kind of been, you know, been time
right after desperate guys time
and some in some way.
I mean, the signal was X for these
three milliseconds and now it changed
to Y these next three milliseconds.
Serves some kind of like funny average
or something like that.
And I guess I guess
the potential concern here
is also that like like
there has to be some way to to link the
the the states as here
as you're kind of bending them
to some sort of policy selection
process, presumably.
And so now I'm not completely sure I can
imagine exactly how that would work.
It's almost like this one is about
the agent deciding which way to walk.
And then maybe there's
some proprioceptive feedback.
But let's think about what
this Decision-Making example is
and then wonder about where the motor
and where these other modalities
and the continuous signal processing.
Also interesting,
let's just walk through this
discrete time
discrete opportunity space model.
And then we talked about like an active
inferred stream eight
with all the chants about
what does it look like
to move active inference
from a discrete into a continuous space.
So the kinds of things
that are actively being developed
and it sounds exciting
about the motor example, Max.
Yeah, I mean, I mean, so there are,
you know, and you know, Thomas
Parr has done a bunch of this
like where he's mixed models, right
where the top the top layer is a discrete
space based Markov decision process model
like this, you know, deciding left arm,
right arm.
But then it feeds into a continuous
state space below that actually controls
the dynamics of the movement itself
based on the decision.
And my guess is it would be more
something more like that would be better.
You know, that being said,
these sorts of these sorts of models
are much more about,
you know, behavior in choice.
I mean, when you're
talking about neural responses,
I would think that would come more
be more useful in these models
to use them to predict
the neural responses that you would get
when a person does
X versus Y and see if that matches
with the firing rates that you see.
That is a paper
mixed model thing
as a paper, I think it's called
like discrete movements to decisions
and back again or something
along those lines in your computation.
Yeah.
I think it deals with all the
formal issues that can arise with this.
Yeah.
Thanks. Okay.
So just for the sake of time here.
So. So again, what I did here
and this is for the agent observing
their own behavior,
all I did was I made it like this, right?
So this is just saying
when the agent chose
a state one,
then it observes the observation
associated with stay one
right row one with 100% probability
when it was in the hinge state,
then observes that it was in the hand
state, wrote to
within a percent probability
and so forth.
So it's just providing maximally precise
evidence so that it knows what it did
So now notice that this was big.
Right. So that's the generative process.
If I wanted to
if we wanted to do reward learning right?
If we wanted it to learn P
when what the reward probabilities are,
then we'd have to set a little AI here.
And you might start out
just sort of making big
a making little equivalent to too big
to start with.
And and multiplying
each of the values
in little by a big number like 200.
And what that does is it just makes it so
the agent is really,
really, really confident
about its beliefs
in a way that our associated with big.
And what that does is it just
prevents learning for anything
you don't want it to learn.
So if you multiply this thing
by really big number,
then it won't learn anything,
even though technically it's learning
because it's just already too confident.
But then
what you could do is for anything
that you do want it to learn
you can just redefine those
with really small numbers, right?
So you can say a three here.
So the probability
of choosing of winning choose
if you choose the left machine,
you know, is point five.
So just point fives all around.
Right. Or 0.25 or whatever.
So this is just saying
that the agent would start with
completely imprecise beliefs
about whether it would win
or lose, depending on what it chose,
depending on context.
So it would. So
this is what you would do.
You kind of turn on a little
if you wanted it
to learn the reward probabilities.
But we're not doing that here.
So we're just showing this as examples.
And same thing. If you wanted to,
you could do the same thing.
But for our commonality, one, to have it
learn like the accuracy of the hint.
Again, these are just kind of common
to our examples.
If you wanted to do that kind of thing,
So now we've defined the the likelihood
matrix, right?
The Matrix, right?
What states generate,
what outcomes with what probabilities?
Now we're moving on in to B,
which are the transition
probabilities.
And remember that
there's one of these per state factor
per action.
So and this is what I showed
before that for B one.
So for state of factor one, the context,
there's only one action, quote unquote.
And it's just an identity matrix
that's just says the last better context
never changes.
But then a trial
and again,
I showed this before
for the second state factor,
the transitions as four different
possible transitions
transitioning from state one
to any of the other states.
So just to be clear here,
and these transition matrices,
the column state of the states here
and now and the rows of the states
that you would move to.
So this is saying from any state
you could move to state, one
from any state
you could move to state to, etc.
So, you know, having,
you know, one, two, three,
four different actions
for that state fact
or four different possible transitions
So now the next thing that we do is
we move to the preference distribution.
So that's C, right?
So this is what the agent wants or what
the agent finds
rewarding
and how rewarding the agent finds it.
So to do that, initially,
we just with no, we just say
what are the different number of outcomes
for each outcome modality.
And that just looks at the size
of the row
dimensions in a.
So if I do that
and again,
this is just using this in a size
function, which is just again, to make it
more convenient or generalizable.
So if I do that then
and is going to look like that, that's
just saying I have three I have three
different outcome modalities.
One is no hair, no no hint and hand
y is null lose and when.
And one is the agent
observing its own behavior.
Right. Observing
action. One, two, three or four.
And can I can I ask me how
many people have asked in the past weeks
about dimensionality of
not to go into the mark
of blanket discussion,
but the dimensionality of observations
and how we talk about different kinds
of outcomes, different kinds of sensors,
for example.
And it's almost looking like it's
just about the way it's specified.
So the hints could be in your ear
and the observation
could be visual or something.
And so you could get philosophical
and ask whether there's really one
or two different sensory modalities.
But in the context of this
inferential model that we're writing,
it's almost like those things
don't really matter.
They're just variables that are observed.
Yeah.
I mean, so again, we call this model
like outcome modalities.
So in this case there's three, right?
So like you said, the hint
this could be the auditory modality
and there's three things I could hear.
This could be the visual modality
and it's the three,
whether it wins or loses or hasn't
seen that yet, or this can be visual
and this four thing, the third
one could be appropriate ception, right?
It could be observing
or feeling what it did.
I mean, in this case, it's
probably also somewhat visual, right?
It observes what it does.
But you got the point yeah. Really? Yeah.
So there's just a nice factorization
dimensionality for each modality.
Yeah.
But okay, so now I have
what I've done is I've started out
by just putting zeros in the C matrix,
the preference distribution
for each outcome modality.
So that's just saying for outcome
modality one.
So the hint the agent has no preferences
and I should say the,
the rows or the observations for the,
you know, no hint, no hint.
I'm going to columns or time.
So as the saying at time one,
the agent doesn't care
whether it gets the hint or not
in terms of rewarding this
same thing
at time to same thing at times three.
And I've just done that for all three
outcome
modalities to start with.
The only thing that we want
to add preferences for
is the win lose observations.
So in this case, so that's C
for outcome modality
to which is the win loss thing here.
So what I've done again
for Generalizability
is I've set this parameter
le that it's called loss aversion.
And I have set this parameter RC,
which is that
reward seeking thing,
which I just defined above as our S1.
And again, it's just convenient.
So I don't have to go down
here, reset it every time
so I define these
just for again, just for convenience.
And then what I say here is
so the observations again are null
is when this is at time zero,
the agent doesn't care
whether it observes a knowledge
loss or a win, and that's
just because it can't observe anything
but a null and at time too,
it just prefers losing with
a value of again, -1 here
for both time, two and time three.
But here's a little bit of a trick
is that I define the preference
for winning as our set time too.
And remember that R's is for right now
because that's what they set it above
their time.
Three I set the preference
as our as divided by two
so what that ultimately means
is that
the this state factor
will look like this or I mean sorry
this this preference distribution
will look like this saying
it dislikes losing equal at H time,
but it once
it gets more reward for winning at time
to then at time three
and so that's our
that's our preference distribution
And this is just all that's basically.
It this is all in how the details
of how the sketched out scenario okay $4
but then you got to wait 20 minutes
and however your scenario is
this is about the detail in matrix
form of how the payoffs work
and so it could be -1 or you might ask
if another number is appropriate there.
But it's kind of like that's
the detail level, that's the applications
and that's where we hope to see
a lot of people
exploring different scenarios
so that we can understand better.
Yeah.
And so and so you'll see that
when we actually do the like fitting
like parameter fitting to behavior,
you know, one thing we'll do
is we'll fit this, right?
So for some people, Rs
might be like eight.
And for other people
it might be like two.
So you find this value for each person
the best explains or reproduces
their behavior.
I mean, you gave that example
last week, right?
In the substance of this example
where actually has really meaningful
all of that parameter
has a really meaningful interpretation.
Yeah, exactly.
Because it has to do with
in the case of an Explorer exploit task,
the lower RSS basically means
the more people, the more like
someone is driven to explore,
you know, before they kind of jump
to conclusions about which one's the best
and just keep choosing that one.
It makes me
it makes me think about maybe in the
substance example or another example.
It's like if we're going to
have a society that rewards good behavior
and punishes negative behavior
or something on some issue,
do you go with here's
how much you get positive and here's
how much the punishment should be
should be small punishment versus large.
These kinds of questions,
which are really important
at the individual and the group level,
not that this is even close
to the answer,
but it's almost like it's a way
for us to start talking about
how much do we value and how much do
individuals need different blends
of these different attributes.
So really a good way to talk about this.
Yeah, absolutely.
You know, and so like
oh, so one thing that I did want to
clarify here is you'll notice
that, you know, these are supposed to be
probability distributions, right?
See, you know,
each column here is supposed to be
something that adds up to up to one.
And technically,
we work with log probabilities.
And so,
you know, -1 and four and -1
and two obviously don't
aren't probabilities
or log probabilities.
So in practice,
this each column here is soft maxed
and then each element is logged,
which is which is how you end up
with the actual log probability
distributions that define the preferences
when they're actually used in the code.
And I show that I show
an example of the numbers
they turn into in the in
or we show them in the in the paper
so you know, last kind
of really central thing
is to define the policies.
So here I'm just going to use NPE here
to define the number of policies
I want to allow.
And here
the next thing is just the number
of actual state factors
and that will just allow me
in a generalizable way to say that V
as a T -1 rows, right?
So it's going to be
the number of actions minus
the number of times
because you have to move from time
to time to time to the time three.
So there's always one less action
possibility than there are times
at a trial.
And the number of policies, again,
is going to be columns.
A number of state factors
is going to be that third dimension.
So I can start by
just a finding that as ones
and I can keep it that way.
I just wrote this explicitly,
so you can see it.
And this just means again,
it can only choose
to stay in the same context every time.
So that's not something
the agent knows or can control.
Whereas for today, factor two, I can
define each of the as possible policies
stay in the start state, take the hint
and then choose the left machine.
You know, take the hand,
choose the right machine,
choose the left machine
and then go back to start user emission.
Now back to start.
And I know describe what
each of those means in this kind of one,
two, three, four, five can get here
so then if we want to
and I'm not going to do this here,
you can specify E
which is the kind of like habits,
you know, essentially
just apply over policies
that biases you toward choosing one thing
versus another. And just one.
And this is.
Run as in the previous active
inference streams.
We talked about that
as the field of affordances
for those who are connecting it
to the ecological psychology or to the
in activism
oh. You mean policy.
Oh. Yeah, sure. Understand that.
The prior the prior on what can be done
among policies
is the affordances
of the organism in their niche.
So if you don't have
the object, it's not going to be a policy
under consideration.
And so e is this mathematical device
that's going to be weighting policies
by their habit basically.
Excellence is a habit,
that kind of thing.
Yeah.
I mean, I guess like,
I mean technically what you're doing is,
you know, like the when this makes sense
functionally is when you're learning it.
So, so what you would do with little E
and so this might start out,
you know, flat,
right with just counts of one
for the duration distribution
but if you choose the same policy
20 times, let's say you choose policy
three 20 times, then this one,
this third one here would become a 20.
And, and so that just means
that you'd start out with a strong bias
now for choosing policy free because
you've chosen it a bunch of times before.
And that's an optimal
thing to do under the assumption
that option three was
the one that continued to have the lowest
expected free energy every time.
Right.
So if in this model based way,
based on minimizing spectra for energy,
you succeeded over and over again
when you chose option three
that it makes sense
to build up this kind of bias
and so that you don't actually
have to work that hard cognitively
to just keep doing the thing.
That's right.
Once you build up a prior
that it's going to keep being right
So I guess I can see how
if you do the same sorts of things
in a given niche over and over again,
then you develop priors
that bias you toward doing the things
that are successful in that niche.
And if something
if something's never been
if something's ever been observed,
then it's unlikely it takes a different
mode of operation outside this script.
If something's never been observed
for it to be considered.
This is just a basic they know the
that's why you initiate
with a non-zero value
because it's something that could happen.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's true.
If you set a zero anywhere
and in E, then it's, it's
as though they don't have that option
yeah, that's true.
One other thing to say is just like
agents can get stuck
if you have non stationary environments.
So say you have 100 trials and one thing
and then you switch
contexts,
the agent will probably be stuck
and so I know it's useful
with all of these parameters.
They have kind of
we can have our favorite interpretations
related to like ecological psychology
or whatever,
but I think it's always useful to kind of
consider them functionally and use
them kind of
appropriately for the city.
So whatever situation is your modeling?
Yeah, yeah.
That's the thing is, is, you know, the,
the most useful places with this
and say like computational psychiatry
are that if you have the right set
of experiences and these models
and you get stuck doing
what's technically Bayes optimal
given your past experience,
but that like makes
you really, really maladaptive
and what you're doing in the new context
that you're, you're in, right?
So you can get stuck in really
maladaptive places in parameter space
that could lead to symptoms
that look like psychiatric symptoms,
for example.
And so, I mean, this is a kind of idea,
you know,
like filtering back as a paper
on this as like, you know,
optimal inference
and suboptimal models, I think. But
the whole
point is you're doing the optimal thing,
but your model is wrong.
Ryan, outside of the.
Optimal thing, under the assumption
that your model is right.
Just outside of this model stream,
which is really amazing
and I hope it will continue.
We would also like to feature
these kinds of direct discussions
about the computational psychiatry.
So this is awesome with a walk through in
the code is going to be helpful
for a lot of people
who are learning that.
And then let's table and find the right
time to talk about these issues
because it's really awesome
what you're describing.
Yeah.
You know, I mean, obviously computational
psychiatry is what I do in breakfast.
Right? So, yeah, I'd love to.
And okay, so finally there's a bunch
of kind of additional parameters, right?
So we talk about learning rate,
which here we're just setting 2.5
for, you know, arbitrarily and beta.
This is the expected
free energy of precision.
So it, it controls
essentially how confident the agent is in
its expected free energy estimates.
And so if this value is low
or sorry, if this value is high,
that means that the agent
is really unconfident
and it's expected free energy estimates.
And when that's the case, then behavior
will be a lot more random
unless the agent has strong habits.
If agent has strong habits,
then having a high beta value
means that the habits will have
a much stronger influence on on policy
and ultimate policy selection.
And we actually show this is the thing
that I was talking about.
It's kind of like a
and random exploration sort of thing
where it's actually updated over time.
So with each observation, the agent
essentially updates its confidence
in its expected free energy estimates
and then Alpha is kind of like a standard
what are called inverse temperature
parameters and where it just kind of
controls randomness and action selection
so once you have chosen a policy,
then that policy might say
this action is better than that action,
but occasionally
the agent might still choose
a different action kind of randomly.
And this is actually
again, this is technically
like a suboptimal thing, right?
You ought to just choose the best thing
but this is actually quite important
to fit in practice
because in actual human behavior,
there tends to be
a notable amount of randomness
and so you need to actually fit something
like Alpha to get a model
that fits behavior well.
Now, these other two things
I'll probably skip over, largely
because they only have to do
with the neural process theory primarily.
But this ERP thing,
it just controls how much beliefs reset
at each time
point with respect to the modeled
firing rate changes.
So it basically controls how much priors
at one time point carry over
at the next time point with respect
to the neural process theory.
And then
Tao is basically looking evidence
accumulation, right?
So that controls how quickly
you update your beliefs
based on new observations and
as attached to the
the neural process theory.
Yeah.
Anyone digs into the code.
Is this a time
constant on gradient descent?
Yeah.
So and I go through a couple
of other ones here that I explain,
but I'm going to kind of skip
over those for now.
So then that's basically a
if we wanted to, we get a hard code
what the states,
what the initial states are
and what the observations are like that
by setting SNL.
But typically what we will do is
we won't do that.
We'll just let the generative process
generate the observations itself,
which is probabilistic.
So it'll generate with whatever
the probability is of the over
D what states are actually
the true states in that context.
And therefore the
observations get generated.
And so the last thing and again,
I already covered
this is you just stick all these things
you defined into this MDP, right?
And we allow a little data, which means
we're going to allow it to learn
whether the left or the right
context is more likely.
We set all these things,
you know, the learning rate
and the action precision
or inverse temperature.
So Alpha etc.
We're going to leave out other things
we could have defined
like E or like learning A or learning
B or learning C or learning A, etc.
We're not going to define
the states ahead of time
and we're not going to define
some of these additional parameters
that we could include
and then we can just kind of
do some nice labeling here
just so we label what the contexts
mean right?
The semantics,
we're laying on it for the figures
and that's it.
And then once we do that,
then we can use this little check
script here
just to make sure we didn't mess
anything up in building the model.
And it'll kind of nicely
tell you or give you a hint anyway
about what you might have messed up.
And then this script that I mentioned
before
that we provide is the one
that actually runs the simulation.
And then finally, once we have
the simulations run,
which will be stored on this big MBP,
then we can use these plotting scripts
to actually show the results.
And if I set them equals one, then it's
going to do that it's just going to
do a single trial simulation,
which I'm going to do now.
So I'll just let the thing run
the rest of the way.
So I want I'll get rid of these stoppers.
Well, just to give a quick
let's give a coding recap
just to where we are
at the end of the second session
while you're going
through the stop signs.
So in the first session, we talked a lot
about the basis of this paper
and the rationale,
and we talked a little bit more
about who might be interested
or what kinds of experiments
it was adjacent to
and then today
that was awesome with the code
because we went through a full definition
and we moved from that sort
of analytical definitions
that we went through
in the first session.
Into seeing how the realized in the code.
And for me
at least, it was really helpful to see
how a lot of these things were put down.
And then we got all the way up to line
six 31 or something,
but could be different
in a little different version,
but we got to
the definition of the full model
and then the call out from that object
to another script, and then we're going
to be storing all the outputs
in this kind of big container called MDP.
So today
we went from zero to 60 with the code
getting all these things run
through and defined and operated on.
Now we're going to look at the output
and then it sounds like in future
sessions
we're going to be fitting parameters
and maybe doing a few other things.
Yeah, and future stuff.
Well, I mean, it sounds like maybe
we're going to wait to do
to show learning next time,
I guess, depending on the amount of time.
But yeah, next time
then we'd be in a position to do
actual code for learning.
We're planning
on covering the neural process theory
and building hierarchical models
and then the last thing is
you actually fitting models to data. So.
So yeah, we'll see how much of that
we can get through.
But okay, so just to finish here,
so I got rid of all my little stoppers,
so now I'm just going to click Continue
and it's going to run Samuel's one
and what I'm going to get out of
this is a little plot like this.
And also there'll be a neural neural
process that you want to under here.
But I'm going to ignore this for now
because we're not talking
about the neural
process theory right now.
So what this
top one here is, is it's hidden states.
So contexts now black equals
a high, probably higher probability
of white equals a low probability.
And so there's, you know,
the gray is kind of in between.
Right?
So this is saying
and these are all posteriors
over states at the end of a trial
so that's important.
So what this is saying
is at the end of the trial at Time three,
these are the beliefs
that the agent has about
what state
it was in across all these timestamps.
So this is saying
at the end of the trial,
the agent was completely confident
that it was in the left better context.
And these little cyan blue dots here mean
that that's what the true context was.
So in other words, the agent was right.
So this is saying
at the end of the trial, the thing was,
the agent was really confident
it was in the left better context.
The other state factors, choice
states down here, and this is just saying
that it observed itself go from the start
state to the hint state and then, well,
sorry, it moved from the start state
to the head of state to the left state.
So those are the states,
the actions correspond to that.
Well, so this is saying at first chose
the hint state
and then it chose the choose
the left state or choose left actions.
Are these the actions
This thing in the middle, on the left,
it's not really important.
It's just kind of depicting
what the different policy options are
kind of arbitrarily based on the numbers.
So I just ignore that
down here at the
bottom, we have the outcomes
and the outcome preference distributions.
So this is just saying it observed null.
And then the left hand and the null.
Again, this
the third one just says that observed it
go to the start state, then to hand state
and then to choose is left.
So just observing its own behavior.
The second one here is the win lost one,
which is the most important.
So you can see that this one actually
has a nonzero distribution over it,
which is what means it
prefers some observations over others
and so in this case, what it's saying
is it started the null state at time to
it stated in the null state.
Right, because it took the hint
and then it observed a win.
So in other words, it got the hint.
It knew what context it was.
It chose the left, chose the left.
And so it observed
when So that's what that means.
And then this distribution
of our policies here is just saying
at the beginning
it wasn't that confident. Right.
So there's a lot of gray
across all the policy options
but after the hint,
it became really confident at time, too,
about what the right policy was.
This bottom thing is
part of the neural process area
simulator dopamine.
So dopamine response is quote
unquote, it's the updates in the expected
precision beta thing,
but that's how you read these plots.
And again, I won't
I won't go over the neural process
very well because we're going to do that
next time, hopefully.
But just the last thing to show is
if you noticed in that case,
the agent went to the head first, right?
So it went for the hand first.
I'll just do that one more time.
So you can see it's
very reliable that it will
and that it will choose the hint
with a lot of confidence.
But now look what happens
if I make this wrist value higher,
if I make it eight, which means that
the thing is really, really early.
Wants to win the $4, basically.
So in this case,
it should be risk taking.
It should just forego the hand
and just take a guess immediately.
And you could see that's what it does.
It has a flat distribution, has no idea
whether it should choose the left or
the right one, but it just takes a chance
because it really wants to win the $4
and value of information
and the expected free energy is low
because the reward value is really high.
And so it just takes a guess
and it guesses
right and it turns out that
it was in the left context.
So it observes that it lost
at time, too.
And because it observed
that it lost in the first
oh, I must have been in the left context
as opposed to the right one.
So at the end, it still knows now
that it was in the left better context.
And so that's so that's what that means.
You can see right away that by changing
how much the thing value is reward
and the preference distribution changes
how information seeking it is versus
our risk seeking.
It is and so that's
so that's the way that that works.
So do we want to end here or
do we want
or is there time to show learning?
We can absolutely go through learning,
if you would like.
So the topics that I've written down,
I have learning, which it sounds like
would be awesome. To run through.
Now, then we have actual data,
hierarchical models,
neural process theories,
and then computational psychiatry.
So that's the stack of topics
let's get to learning today.
And then another time,
another model stream
Okay.
Sounds good.
So learning.
So if you can say
I sort of said how to do this here.
I said for to reproduce figure seven
so four figure nine here,
which is some two,
which is the initial learning.
I'm going to first set
ours to three.
It's just a value
that turns out it's nice
for showing that an Amex of learning
in a way that's clear.
And so because it should start out
being information seeking
and we want to show us how it learns
to be more confident
and therefore starts to forego
the hint as it builds up a stronger prior
that the left context
is the one that keeps being the case.
So now what I'll do
is I'll set some equals to,
but I'll show
you what this does down
when I go to some equals to
blah, blah, blah.
Okay.
So this is actually incredibly simple.
So and similarly to a set,
all I do is I say, okay,
I want 30 trial so and equals 30.
And to keep the MDP thing
something that remains
and then just kind of single structure
I redefine little as big and deep.
And again, this is just for convenience.
And then I can use this deal function
which is just kind of a nice convenient
function in MATLAB,
which more or less just says
repeat the MVP structure 30 times.
So now there's MVP one, maybe two, MVP
three and all those are just
the same, just identical
as the initial MVP that we built.
And so if I do that then what will happen
is it will look like so okay,
so I'll do so I'll do two things.
One is
so before
and so now I just have big MVP
equals all MVP.
So now
big MVP will look like this, right?
This just a single field for TV,
a B, blah, blah, blah, right?
Everything that we saw
and now once I run this deal thing,
then if I step, then all of a sudden MVP
will now look like this.
Where you can see now
that same structure
is repeated in 30 rows
and this will all start out
being identical.
So what will happen now, though, is
if I run it through the VB
X tutorial script, then
and this will take a second
and we'll run through the whole thing
30 times
and again, this will just take a sec.
So wait, let me ask something.
So first, maybe someone maybe
has a little noise in the background, but
it seems like this
little MDP is like a column that conveys
all the details for a single trial,
and then we're making a better matrix.
We're just generalizing the matrix
into many dimensions.
And now we're stacking
all of the total model as a column into,
in this case, 30 trials.
But you could do 100 trials in a row,
or you could have 20 sets of ten trials
since the idea of concatenating
total model set ups like a column
so that you can do operations on big,
big potentially hierarchical sets
of models.
In this case, each and AP is a row.
It's just a giant model.
Yeah, it's just a giant structure
with over and over again.
Yeah, I meant Ro Start could call it
my R centrism.
I'm always like thinking in column.
Yeah.
All right. But okay, so now I ran it.
I ran the MVP
with all those different repeated,
repeated roles, repeated models
through this MVP
script here and now
what you'll see is now the MVP structure
will look a little different
so now in addition
to all the stuff in it I had before,
it's also now going to have
all this,
oh, this thing is like being now.
It's going to have all this other stuff.
It's going to have the free energy.
If it's going to have the expected
free energy,
it's going to have the total for energy
h it's going to have the actions
you it's going to have the free energy
for the learn parameters
d bunch of other stuff.
And we have a whole table in the
in the tutorial
that says what each of these fields
mean so you can interpret them.
They don't
all matter enough for me
to go through them right now.
But so then once I have that
then I can generate
a plot with this little game
underscore tutorials script
that I for plotting multiple trials
that we put together
and I can run that
and it will generate
multi trial there so.
So what this is showing
is the first action on each trial.
And so here
what you can see is that and the start
and the colors of the probabilities
so dark equals
higher probability and the blue circles
are the actual chosen actions.
So you can see for the first several
trials the agent kept taking the hint
but after a while because the left one
if the left contacts kept being the one,
the one that it thought it was in
at the end
it starts to be confident around trial
nine ten here
that it's
always going to be the left one.
So it just immediately chooses the
the left arm or the left machine.
But now what you can see
is, is that it gets one wrong, right?
Because the it's only 80% right
that the left one
is going to be the right one. And.
And once
one to the dog, could a dog be meters
or so that year.
Yes it is.
It is in a dog
wanting to want it to be in my lap.
But the dogs are contributors
and absolutely.
Welcome to speak. Yes.
I thought.
But anyway so it starts to get one
wrong here on trial.
12 right the 13 because again
it's only even
when it's in the left better context
it still will lose 20% of the time.
Right.
And so once it loses
it says okay actually
I'm not confident anymore
so start taking the hint again.
And that happens a couple of times.
And so it starts kind of going
bouncing around
and, and also note that this, this
is under an alpha value, right?
Like the actual precision value
that's not that high.
So its behavior
is a little random, right?
There's a little bit of randomness in it,
like what a real human would do.
And so this next caller,
this next plot here below is just green
as a win, black as a loss.
And the you can see when it loses
the negative energies
are larger
and again, this
I want to go through these last
these two here are just part
of the neural process theory.
They're like the expected
groups and expected domain responses.
The model the theory would predict
and then the slope bottom line is
just kind of the evolution of the agents
priors about whether it's going to be
the left one or the right one context.
So that's how to
read this so it learns and then but look
what happens if I instead make the thing
a little bit more
risk seeking.
So I make the the value of the
the subjective
value of winning $4 more.
And I do that just by
setting Rs to four instead of three.
In this case.
So now
by the way, it's
awesome that basically
by hitting play on this script,
it seems like even with minimal
tweaking, people can reproduce this
in their own setup.
Starts at play
with some of the variables,
and it's just really an awesome tool kit.
This is pretty cool.
Yeah. No, thank you.
Yeah, we we definitely tried to make it
as easy as
User-Friendly as possible
for people to have minimal background.
So glad if you guys think so.
But okay, so, so in this case, right?
I set the risk seeking parameter
and the preference distribution
to be a higher number.
So now if you look, the agent is now
it takes the hand twice
and then just sticks
with the left every single time.
Even if it
loses a couple of times,
it just continues to be a risk seeking
and, and again, everything else is
basically the same except the,
the predicted domain responses and groups
and things like that are different.
But but so that is what it looks like
when you just do
like a normal learning
just where it says the same.
The context is the same across trials
and the last thing I'll show you guys
is if I set it to three,
then we engineer this kind of this
reward learning
or this reversal learning version, right?
So our virtual learning
is for the first several trials,
the left context is better.
So it's going to build up a prior
the the left context is better
but then it's going to switch to
the right context being better and more.
We're going to see how the agent does.
Now, I'll show you
how we do that,
which is also very simple here.
We're going to set end to be 32 trials
through the same kind of,
you know, deal thing.
But now what I did is I just said
for one to
the number of trials divided by eight,
we're going to make big.
The 10 is saying the true neural process
or the true generative process
is going to be the left one.
But then I say in the MDP four
and divided by eight plus one plus
one to N so basically one
after this number to the end,
then it's going to now
be switched at the generative process
as the right context.
And so in this case,
it just means the first a the first eight
trials are left better
and the rest of the trials up to 32
are going to be the right better context.
So that's literally it.
Then just run the same thing
through the same vbox function and
you plot it with the same plot script.
So that's really very, very simple.
So if
I do that with risk, speaking of three
then what we'll see happen is
that, you know,
give it a second to look here.
Just to give one note on that software
design, instead of having five scripts
called simulation
one simulation two, simulation three,
it's like there's a Common Core.
And then the simulation scenarios
are defined basically
like variables down here in the six
hundreds lines.
And then by changing which simulation
is in play at the very top, it seems like
Ryan is being able to change
which simulation we're in very fluidly.
So we can change the simulation.
Look at a variable, change a variable,
go back up, change the simulation,
go back in
yeah.
I mean, it's basically it's just a it's
just an if then function,
it just says if SIM equals three,
then do this.
Or else if SIM equals four, do this.
Yeah.
I mean, it's
just a very simple statement.
But but okay.
So in this case, and so I set our
as equals three.
And what you can see is, is in this case,
the agent just continued to take the hint
the entire time
because it was never
it was never confident enough.
And the, you know, and it happened
to get the first one wrong
in this case,
which is part of what drove that
but so if they if the actual observations
they got were a little different,
let's actually try that again
and see what
what I would get here.
But this characterizes
all these interesting things like a
perhaps over or under eagerness to ask
for hints or acquire more information.
It's showing how the model this one
is not trying to fit human behavior.
We're really playing with the bare bones,
but already we're seeing that's kind of
pathological hint taking behavior,
but it never goes when it knows.
And so now it's something else. Yeah.
Well, it's just it's parameter play,
but it's going to play like yeah.
So like in this case, right?
It does take the hint every time.
It does kind of start.
You can see on Trial five here,
it starts to have a little bit of like,
oh, maybe I should just choose the lab
choose the left one immediately,
but then it gets a couple wrong
and then the context changes.
You can see in context learning here,
it starts out, Oh,
I think the left one's better,
and then I start switching.
And then around trial, 11 and 12.
Now it starts to become more and more
confident that in the right win context.
So now last thing I'll show you
is what happens under that same thing,
but when I set are as equal to four.
So it's a little more risk seeking
because this actually gets
a little more fun.
So the risk seeking
is like a multiplication on the money.
So it's like one to $2 versus
1 million to 2 million, like how high
the stakes are
because it sounds like you're
kind of tuning up whether the agent
wants the big wins or what
is it really conveying in this model?
It's just it's just essentially the
precision of the preference distribution.
So it's just it's
just how big the number is
over when at times step two.
But that's really all it is.
It's just how high the probability
is for a win in the agents model,
which just encodes
how strongly they prefer winning.
And you can think about it
as like $4 for them
subjectively
being like the value of $10 or something.
Like that.
But, but all it ends up doing in
practice is it ends up saying the
reward value component of expected
free energy has a higher weight
than the information value component,
as is all it ends up being in practice.
And so here you can see that the behavior
is actually, you know, again,
it's more interesting.
So you could say it takes the hint twice
and all of a sudden it's like,
all right,
I'm confident enough I'm going to go
for choosing the left immediately.
Right.
And it does that for review trials
and then the context switches,
you know, so at trial
it switches to being the right context.
And then it's like, nope,
I'm going to start taking the hint again.
And then it observes the right one
a bunch of times.
And then it's like, okay.
And now I'm confident it's the right one.
And then it starts
choosing the right one of that,
taking a hit a bunch of times.
Now, the behavior is quite a bit more
interesting because it becomes confident,
it loses confidence
that switches to being confident again.
And the other thing.
Again, it gets one wrong around 23
it gets a wrong one,
and then it does one hint and then it's
like, Nope, I'm on the right track.
I just lost one time. It's all good.
Yep, exactly.
So, so that's,
that's the way the learning works.
And if I show you, you know, like,
I'm in and plotting this here,
but like literally in the MVP,
like it will just be
if I go to the things learning D, right?
So if I go to a little D trial, one
and then, you know, it observes.
Yeah, it's 0.75.25 because that observer
left the first time.
Right?
And then at, you know, say like trial A
it's 2.22.2
it didn't make. It
because that's what it's considered.
A flat was flat still,
but that's because it got some wrong.
That's when it was most confusing.
Yeah.
And then but if I go down to say, like,
you know, at the end, say like trial,
I don't know, 31 or something,
then all of a sudden
it's two versus 13, right?
So it's way more confident.
It's added a lot more counts to it
being the right context.
That's better.
And that's, you know, that's really it.
And so
and that's what all the learning is.
And, you know, like a
cross
showed you the equation for learning a
but you know, in the,
in the tutorial paper
we also show it for, for learning
D which is even simpler.
It's just see if I can get to
a real quick here
learning process.
A learning.
Yeah, it's literally just this.
So D for the next
trial is D for the previous trial.
Plus at times,
whatever the posterior states were
for the previous trial,
that's you know, that's literally it
although I'm realizing
that should
be a minus, not an equals, I think, but
a little typos here and there.
But anyway, that's, you know,
that's really it.
And so it's not a
it's not complicated at all.
It's just add account based on what
your posterior was overstates
at the end of the last trial.
So, I mean, that's
you know, if we're stopping
at the end of basic learning,
then then that's really it.
And like I said, four and five
have to do with estimating parameters
based on data and then recovering
parameter estimates and feeding behavior
to data and things like that.
So we'll cover that at another time.
Awesome.
Well, just to catch our breath
at the end of this,
really fascinating
and very appreciated stream.
And if anyone wants to
put any last comments in the live chat,
they'll have just a couple of minutes
to do so.
Let's just each take a final recap
or a final thought
what do we want to remember
from this time?
What are we going to say
forward into next time?
What are we looking forward
to learning more about?
So whoever wants to go first,
maybe Christopher,
any remarks on Ryan's presentation
and then on the code
and also like your role
or which part had you done?
I was just curious about that.
Wallace things for the last.
So know,
I think I agreed with everything you said
there one thing to just say very one
when you really get your get a handle
on building these models,
it will take, I think the most time
I've ever spent building these models.
Once we actually figured out the model
structure was a couple of days like
you might spend a very, very long time
figuring out the model structure.
But once you figure out the model
structure, everything falls in place.
It's super easy.
So it's kind of interesting in the sense
that I've some friends
do like you're on network
or modeling with like spiky neural nets
and they can spend like weeks
building these models
The the hard work
here is really conceptual.
And then you ask like,
what part of the tutorial
I wrote all investors, Ryan,
was that the question?
Not a partitioning.
Just which parts were your background
drawing from or just
how do you see it similar differently?
I wrote them generally speaking,
I wrote the mathematical appendices
and then did like first drafts
of a lot of the techie sections.
But that was kind of like my
I really really asked Ryan to do that
just because I wanted to kind of get
a better understanding of myself.
And then Ryan kind
of wrote a lot of the broader sections
that was going to help, stuff like that.
And yeah, I mean, I mean, yeah, I wrote
I mean, I wrote
the code were going through now was, was,
you know, I took the first pass at
Chris wrote the
hierarchical model in code
and which another, another day
you'll see.
And a lot of the neural process
simulation code
or that kind of custom one,
the ones that are showing in
ours is kind of like Carl Standard,
the ones that are in a spam but
it's a way,
way cooler ones for the hierarchical
unreal process simulation stuff.
So yeah, I mean a lot of this was a fully
collaborative of, you know, I wouldn't
necessarily say, you know, one person
did anything more than the other.
And so
everyone
seems like written a scientific paper.
No, it's like it's after
the first draft has been written.
That's kind of hard
to tell the finished product
because when you have heavy backward
and forward editing it.
Yeah.
I totally agree.
It's a great perspective.
So also thanks for sharing that.
So maybe now
let's have our last little round, maybe
Max or we'll each take a last step
yeah.
I'm just,
you know, as a lead into next week,
I'm excited to hear
about the neural process theory
and really about, you know,
looking at those dopamine traces
and it's it's cool to see the spiking
that you are able to reproduce
with this kind of a model structure
that does reflect, you know, kind of how
the exact form
that our biological processes might look.
One thing
I'm really keen to hear about is the,
you know, the link
function between your, your gradient
on free
energy and your dopamine express
are stimulated dopamine expression levels
and the postulated link between,
you know, precision insofar as I mean,
I mean, these are things that I'm just
it's a little out of my realm.
But I think it's really interesting
because fundamentally that's
that's such an elegant mechanism.
If it's that gradient
only from a mathematical standpoint
that it's really cool to tie that
from math and theory
into empirical observation
and using that to validate the model.
Or preferred one.
Definitely.
While we're excited
to, we're excited to show you a nice job.
If you want to make any last comments.
Know that this has been really fun.
Thanks, Daniel. Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Thanks everyone talking this whole time.
So yeah, yeah.
Again, people really do want to hear me.
Bramble anymore.
Not so next time at least.
But yeah, thanks everyone for watching
life and in replay and everything
and just for participating
because it's the conversations
we're having the real time
errors we're finding and the learning
that we're all contributing to.
So just thanks everyone
for participating,
and we'll see you later for not.
We'll see you later tonight.
We'll see you later
tonight. We'll see you the.